hey how's it going Brad just about
welcome back to until dawn I've been
away this weekend for pax and we have to
wait love so I know what are they
talking about oh that is garden so seen
it before
what are you talking about oh it's all
these old pictures of some guys have
that scar and he was transforming into a
Wendigo no kidding so we're not miners
have been trapped back in the 50s in a
cave in which means that thing is 80
years old at least
lucky for an old-timer replace Wendigo
with penis and it gets funny if you're
Chinese like me how many do many
how can you tell she has a census okay I
bend in packs
whatever I don't care there's no other
way through em and I I was so annoyed
that I couldn't finish the game before I
left because I really really want to
know how it ends
I'm so into it and you bros got really
into it - it was really cool to see
while I was gone so one possible outcome
is that the whole [ __ ] tavern burned
sets.i rata right I'm glad I find that
totem so many of you bros like why don't
you find that [ __ ] totems I'm sorry I
try why is she going in why the [ __ ] is
she going in no it's not okay hahaha
how gives you don't feel your fingers
they're not even dipped bad bad a pap
how do you know where should we go
something over here I'm not gonna follow
that [ __ ] because otherwise you bros
black why what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you oh I'm making out with a pole I
swear to God I saw some their UI might
offend there you are they could
seriously freeze to death I guess that
doesn't apply in this game that's okay
that's alright with me day one my little
sister is dead the fall killed her
I watched the color drained from her
face my leg is broken
I'm all alone stuck here with best body
someone will come soon a day five I've
never been so hungry it feels like my
stomach is twisting around inside
I took Beth sweater much warming now
she's she's still looking at for me day
30 cannibalism
I don't understand that if you survive
30 days no one's gonna find you I
wouldn't sing solo and eat my sister I'd
rather just die you know what's the
point my hands feel and clean my nail
spell out pushed out I'm aching for MA
but no more cold no pain I'm getting
stronger
further writing devolves into Krauss
skräuss I mean of course I'm trying to
change paths page oh it that was the end
all right well that was cool sorry so
what did she kill her too her own sister
I don't know how the hell could they
even stay alive down I don't know
Michael there has to be an answer down
here like a rat I rat around pretty sure
she became a Windigo it's a pretty
black-and-white that [ __ ] [ __ ] are we
going here oh my god move Mike what
about over here
that's a stool I love me no I can't walk
there well what am i doing then maybe
this area was just for like finding that
no it's so dark for me or I lit up the
game play for you bros don't be like
Mike get your [ __ ] together Mike Oh what
if I could just walk up here no well
alright well Mike he's so awkward like
what is he doing
god damn Mike Mike was on a bike say I
should be a rapper that was pretty good
yeah now your fingers are freezing if
you dip up your [ __ ]
are we playing Mike
all right I think this is where we were
supposed to go see I find something I
know how to find things that were
obvious already but now we close your
eyes and listen to that again we did it
all right
we find something here now I feel like I
have to scavenge every corner which I
don't really want shiny what is this oh
my god why it should have said like go
down click here all right that's the
game's faults not mine
all right don't look at me like that oh
yeah and you can see this too we made
her a lot braver that's cool what about
the butterfly effect you bros telling me
to check this [ __ ] out too well I don't
really care I don't know what to tell
you man woman dinosaur thing all right
here we go progressing sorry I'm a slow
today all right I might oh my god
oh well that's creepy
oh that's really [ __ ] creepy Oh God
ooh I got the goose epoxies oh no it's
that Mike I mean not Mike
yeah it's then she got him you guys
literally have no defense
jump-scare in three two one
thank you Thank You Josh that was that
was a good monologue Full Metal Jacket
we didn't think you'd get you bound here
weeks a month
like a good time in a tell someone Oh
casual nice
if you help me up I go back to tell the
others Roque yeah yeah you bring Josh
back the way we came and while I'm at
the lodge be careful what is she like a
climber ha ha ha ha yeah [ __ ] weird
are we playing is Josh we are playing
his job he look like an old mechanic
what's up with that I mean I know he has
this outfit or whatever but you like it
[ __ ] I'm gonna check over here because
okay let's look at this totem what did
we got Oh shame
how is that fortune I guess if you're
into skinny bitchin [ __ ] bitchin okay
jocks walked a little bit like he [ __ ]
his pants he probably did to be fair it
seemed like he was pretty scared that'd
be funny he sits down later and then
just mush
am I the only one thinking about these
things okay
you know what I'll just be quiet from
now on while playing as Josh he's my
favorite
he's my babies my boobies my bad bad I'm
Eddie Babu is that our friend yeah it is
no starting to feel bad for Josh he just
wanted to prank because it's appropriate
to prank people when your sister died
from a prank it makes sense
oh god no [ __ ] no I ain't going down
that [ __ ] no good I'm good
Oh God how did Josh and up here anyway
Josh does don't dip your fingers
whatever you do don't dip your feet FIPS
yes
jump-scare no goddamn there's sharks oh
god he's dead he's dead
ah oh my god in my sister she has to
tattoo she used to be so pretty
No uh-huh [ __ ] my face oh god no oh well
he's dead
oh we please Jessica now we're getting
close to dawn too
I've been through some [ __ ] someone make
me a movie on IMDB said called don't
look and apparently people are saying it
was inspired by this game
all right opposite sorry go Jessica yay
that bad I'm Jessica can't get anything
okay
I'm Jessica I'm so scared the [ __ ]
jump scares in this game man
someone should you make like a jump
scare compilation of every [ __ ] jump
scare in this game
well I'm glad I walked here Babette a
bat bat bat bat Buddha it's many a theme
song in life someone sent me a long
concerned tweet that doesn't make sense
to return long about how I'm a pervert
it's like it's obvious Jesus Christ how
can you not know this oh my god let's
just try and make it out of here live
this is to go Jessica be careful let's
follow the tracks Oh God
I really want as many characters as
possible to live and I'm trying to do it
I have [ __ ] up once the other time I
think I just got our market
she looks so tired oh my god oh god it's
coming close there oh good good that's
what I was hoping for Oh God okay
oh god I'm [ __ ] on edge today Jesus
Christ uh
I'm gonna try and run she doesn't look
fit to run I regret this decision for
[ __ ] sake
really really really just cuz I made the
wrong decision I hate myself [ __ ] out
your game
goddammit literally right before I said
I want as many people oh god I'm so
pissed off oh god this game in all like
heavy rain or whatever [ __ ] beyond
you can at least go back that's why this
game is so intense I know it's good but
it's hard I am goddamnit
just get up just get dumped done just
get up yeah you're talking to yourself
alright just go home go home oh my god
I'm so [ __ ] pissed seizes [ __ ]
Christ
so happy that Jessica was back there
we're gonna bang okay
hey what all right let's go for help I'm
in such a hurry to again goddamn
Wendigos left and right I don't even
[ __ ] understand Jesus [ __ ] Christ
good job Jessica good running Jessica
did you get it Jessica
it's [ __ ] outfit in this weather two
blushes been water we're gonna walk on
the lake oh god is it oh yeah we are
[ __ ] trying to walk around that's so
stupid isn't it don't dip your fingers
that bad bad bad bad but there there we
go oh god oh god oh god
just do it there we go we're fine we're
fine yeah we did it come on Jessica
no her name is on Jessica goddamn it I'm
tired here we go here no let's just go
here then this is great doing good
ready to go home and have some hot
chocolate with marshmallows extra
marshmallows because I [ __ ] our night
[ __ ] good job just again I don't like
this
it's too quiet oh god what did I say
run run run
Oh God
Oh what oh no terrible
I love worse if we stay out here go on
is that really him is that really him
maybe it's a fake
oh and so now you can think logically
way to go
not good
why do you think we should do we should
check the basement might be someone left
down there that's a very nice pot all
right basement it is that back that
better Pepa basement don't know where
the basement is apparently it's this way
hey hey 'lord basement no basement we
did it
there's a lot of [ __ ] in the air Jesus
Christ must be so much [ __ ]
Oh God
I can't make decisions I'm sorry what
are you doing
Oh God
I've seen this in the totem ain't
Jurassic Park you're moving muscles
ah
those bland [ __ ]
oh they don't like each other holy [ __ ]
oh oh this place is about to pop what's
your plan when I say three what forget
this matrix Oh
oh my god I don't like this
thank God
that's enough to cause a gas explosion
obviously I'm gonna save Mike okay she
made it out oh god she's sexy she's
really [ __ ] sick
I swear to God I did not move I swear
I'm done
game I'm done [ __ ] you no I didn't move
I did not move I know if I move all
right
this is moving this is not moving all
right game
you can't kill two characters the bros
are gonna kill me
come on come the [ __ ] all right [ __ ] a
duck in the [ __ ] bite okay don't
worry don't worry you can replay endings
Nozomi applies
system straight up [ __ ] [ __ ] and
I'm really pissed right now
god [ __ ] damn it that is total oh oh
we made it to dawn now well that's just
great
we made it with 3m
[ __ ] they're supposed to be fired
I'm sorry I think I'm one my I think I'm
on my period all right that Buddha
literally I waited four days to finish
25 minutes but we did it
what's that ending what's that the
ending that we got was a shitty ass
ending don't worry we will get another
ending I know how to make them all live
now I know how to make them all live all
right we're gonna do it so frustrating I
feel like I worked on it you know
okay he's she's talking about a penis
I'm sure of it he held it right up to my
face almost shot me the prick I mean you
go out with a guy for however long and
you think you know him but man this one
really takes the cake
he's out his [ __ ] mind you wanted to
hurt us
Hey
I thought he was the one who attacked
Jess I heard Jessica I don't know how or
why she was down there but I know I
heard her about Matt have you found him
no not yet yeah well don't look too hard
you don't sound very concerned [ __ ]
left me to die he said he was my
boyfriend but then he basically murdered
me would you give a [ __ ] I I stabbed him
and I tried to get away but I didn't
know I swear I didn't know didn't know
who did you stabbed
oh I stabbed the maniac I didn't know it
was Josh but then he was the second
house it was a no Josh I know the saws
and the gonna know Josh helped us and
then [ __ ] man that thing
okay the wendigo it came out of the
darkness and it just I don't know I
heard screaming I got out of there
there's no point both was dying
what happened
why inskipp okay
goddamnit here we go
this is dandy
so creepy
Oh Josh see now we can go to episodes
and we can redo like the last part which
I think we should do do you Bruce want
to do that let's check out this is
really cool checking out new stuff CD
see the actresses and actors or meet the
cast
faster oh my god oh my god Brett oh my
god you look so different
oh my god he's the same that's so cool
alright let's do let's do it you know do
it select an episode to replay and
change the story oh that's awesome
so okay we're gonna fix everything okay
sorry I changed my mind you know what
we're gonna do you bros are gonna help
me out so let me know in the comments
what I should do each episode please to
get the best ending or the ending you
bros want to see cuz i'm not sure
exactly what i should change or what
parts so let me know in the comments
alright other than that i have to say
though that this game has been such an
amazing experience it has to be
probably like it feels like a classic
it's so it's so it brings to heavy rain
concept to a new level and to have a
horror games around it it was just so
cool
I think and this was a blast and I think
you brothers really enjoyed it too and
this is kind of like how how this
channel has it kind of fallen away from
doing series mainly because I don't know
usually what to play and I really want
to play games that I am personally
really excited about but also that you
both really enjoy so it's kind of hard
to find those kind of titles and I think
this was the perfect match I think this
is the perfect game for that so just
seeing you rose excitement every day for
a new video and and for me to play this
has just been a complete joy so I just
want to thank you both so much really
for watching this series it's it's such
a dream for me to be doing what I'd be
doing especially about while doing stuff
like this that was such a weird sentence
but you get my point
alright we're gonna end this episode
here and I'll see you with another bonus
episode we check out some extra style
alright stay awesome bros